CIA agent for 27 years cheap disguise
officer with her husband Tony Mendez if
you've seen the movie Argo he is the
main character played by Ben Affleck so
I've heard of CEOs the what is it chief
disguise officer we would lie for a
living
trying to keep our foreign agents safe
we use disguise everywhere in the world
one of the first mass that came out of
production turn me into a younger better
costed woman judge Webster likes it he
said well let's take it to the White
House so I peeled off my face what
really like he almost fell off his chair
you're a spy how can you tell somebody
else is a spy we trained them not to
look for surveillance but to always
assume they were there because they
always were there and they arrested a
lot of them and they executed and
Hatta CIA control me not saying anything
to anybody so today we have a special
guest with us who was a CIA agent for 27
years in and afterwards she became the
cheap disguise officer which we're gonna
find out what that is today and she
wrote a book called the Moscow rules
with her husband Tony Mendez who if
you've seen the movie Argo he is the
main character played by Ben Affleck and
by the way just so you know that the
this back view here is not a backdrop
this is not a green screen okay this is
the real view that's the White House
behind us if you're watching close
you'll see the flag movement so with
that being said our yesterday
Jonah Mendez Jonah could see have you on
the show with us so what does it take to
be a CIA agent I mean how do I become a
CIA agent if I if I'm growing up I'm
saying one day I want to be a CIA agent
how do I do it you know most of the CIA
people I met didn't grow up wanting to
be one they all kind of it they came
into it through all kinds of different
doors the main motivation is desire to
serve your country and they find very
unique possibilities and working for the
CIA you're not working at GSA you're not
in the military but you are supporting
the country you're making a difference
you're doing a job that hopefully
matters and if you get the right job you
probably could even enjoy doing it the
motivation varies person to person but
everybody that I've ever known that
worked for the CIA treated it almost
like it was a calling
almost I could call it they don't pop
around to other jobs they don't work
there for three years and then go off to
the next to the next job daughter they
stay they might move around within CIA
but they stay within CIA is the CIA
recruit me or do I go pliancy I'd like
to work for you because you know there's
this for those who are not in the world
they wonder is somebody coming out to
recruit yours it's you apply it goes
both ways
okay my husband Tony was he was an
artist working in Denver he saw an ad in
the paper now this is years ago it said
artists to work overseas for the US
government he's an artist he's working
at Mary Martin Marietta he's doing
wiring diagrams he's drawing them for
harnesses for titan-2 missiles this is
not art he's an artist he wants so he
replied to the to the ad it was the CIA
they wanted an artist gotta be she's
thinking what what would they do with an
artist they need someone with exquisite
hand-eye coordination to do some
documents for them to copy some things
for them you could call it
counterfeiting you can call it forgery
but that's what he was really really
good at and that's what they hired him
for and that's how he got into it that's
how he got it so let me ask you so when
he went to the interview at what point
did he find out it's the CIA the way he
tells it he's on the outskirts of Denver
in a kind of seedy motel room with the
guy who's actually wearing a hat the guy
pulls up a bottle of bourbon it sets it
on the table pulls out up a book full of
classified ads from the CIA goes you
read it I'm not I'm not sure but this is
what they're looking for they kind of
knew then so he knew kinda then that
that's the case he knew it wasn't just
the US government so at what point was
so after that is it kind of like either
you accept or you don't is there a
follow-up process to it there's an
enormous background investigation that
is so slow and so mm thorough that a lot
of people just fall by the wayside they
can't wait they can't wait that long a
year
what's one year at least yeah so so I
sit down I do an interview after that
there's about a year plus process of
them accepting me very likely it's it's
a year what what are some things they
want to know about me they want to know
if you're if you're being sent by a
foreign government they want to know if
you're really a patriotic American they
want to know if you have any criminal
background they want to know if you've
ever been arrested for drugs they want
they'll go visit your neighbors your
teachers your your friend's parents
they'll check you out thoroughly
thoroughly
call them references that talking to
them in the most indirectly without
bringing up the fact that it's going to
be one of my best friends told me years
later she said you know when you when
you were in Europe and I you've been
gone a while this man came and knocked
on the door he said he was investigating
you she said for the for the government
and I told him she said what I knew it
but she said I thought maybe maybe you
had married some guy who was a janitor
or something he wouldn't say where you
were working he wouldn't say what he was
what you were doing and what the work
was just checking you out
Wow yeah and I know you had a friend of
yours that didn't know you were CIA
agent for 20 years and she was hurt
apparently that she found out later on I
couldn't tell her we talked we talked
all the time and you still couldn't tell
her I couldn't tell her some people
asked me what you did what'd you tell
him
independent independent what independent
contractor it depended on where I was
living it depended on where I'm living
and what environment I was in and then I
could carve out a piece of it and that's
where I worked so here in Washington DC
you could say the Pentagon you could say
State Department sometimes it depended
on who you were talking to because if
you already told me that you worked at
State Department I'm not gonna tell you
that I do got it if you're a heart
surgeon I'm not gonna tell you I'm a
heart surgeon to God so you had to kind
of feel your way got it got it but you
had to do that
how were you recruited mine is uh -
boring I'm married my first husband who
worked for the agency I didn't know that
he worked for the agency until right
before the wedding we got married in
Switzerland then we went to the Far East
and I needed a job so I got a job with
the CIA at the station we came back home
and I got another job I just kind of
Segway into it work your way up yeah so
the first reaction when he told you I'm
a CIA agent what was that like I was
from Wichita Kansas I don't think I even
know what the CIA was back there god
yeah got it
it didn't register so you and your
husband you were 27 years CIA he was 52
years that's he was 25 years of combined
27 years how was it being married to CIA
agent were both of your CIA agents
perfect is it really it wasn't it wasn't
because we
understood yeah what the other one was
doing but we still couldn't necessarily
talk about everything we were doing so I
know I was
I never say where I worked I can't say
where I worked I was in the subcontinent
I came home he had a conference he said
tell me you have that thing you're doing
this is my boss he's my boss back then I
said well I can't tell you who your
husband was your boss back down he
wasn't my husband he was just my boss he
was two tears up my boss he said tell me
about that I said I can't tell you about
it you're not on the list you know I
told him later if I had known I was
gonna marry you years and years and
years later I would have maybe told you
you told him that except do you trust
him do you trust being married to a CIA
agent like because they know they're a
pro like you is what how do you handle
that that's really one of the key
questions when you're working yeah it's
one of the real compliments you can give
a colleague you can say I would work
with you I would work with you you know
we go off to far-flung places and and
where there's there's really no support
and where everything you need you have
to have with you you have to pack that
bag you have to trust that person to to
have your back it's a very symbiotic
kind of relationship to say I trust you
I would work with you it's a big deal we
would lie for a living so there was this
thing called a moral compass you used to
talk about it because we lied for living
but when we weren't working you couldn't
do any more lying the difference that
you had to make sure that you kept those
two things separate it's important that
you kept them separate yeah that's what
I wonder some of these you know Aldrich
Ames some of these these these
no-goodniks that we had working for us
they just lost their way they really
lost if there was ever a line for them
they lost it so when you're saying I
would work with you
there are some people obviously wouldn't
work with and I were saying that because
you don't trust them I would I would I
would not trust them with my operation
or with my agents life so then why would
the CIA keep them so isn't that kind of
a credibility for you to be able to say
if CIA trust John so will I or that's
not the case
see I you could have John but you may
not still trust John and want to do an
operation with them
I might not think John was as
accomplished as other other people did
there would be a difference of opinion
there I would maybe not want to work
with him maybe I had worked with him and
I knew that when when when push came to
shove he wasn't there I had a boss like
that that I couldn't say I wouldn't work
with him I had to work with him but when
I did it was I had to cover all the
bases and make sure that everything was
right because the thing I think about is
okay you said somebody who gets into the
CI it's not like I worked three years
and I'm gonna go be a cop then I'm gonna
go work sales at Sears then I'm gonna go
sell shoes and I'm gonna go do this they
stay in it for a while most of the
people have one time I had a region I
was in California was part of Vistage
Vistage is where they have entrepreneurs
come to get us like a board one of the
speakers we brought was the regional CIA
director for a West Coast and we had him
come speak and he spoke to us for an
hour questions we were asking he
couldn't tell us why for 25 years and he
kind of told her he worked for the
government but wouldn't tell her all
this stuff but question I asked that I'm
curious on of what you're gonna say
about this is so I work for the CIA
hypothetically and all of a sudden
things are not working out
I leave the CIA how does CIA control me
not saying anything to anybody
what is the accountability there they
can't so I can say anything to anybody
if I want to not exactly for instance
this book that I've just written I can
write down anything I want I can put it
I could be like a dictionary they have
the right every everyone who works for
the CIA signs away their right to the
written word you can you the CIA can
review my written words and if you find
something classified in there you have
the right to remove it you cannot remove
something that you don't like it's just
because you don't like it but if it's
classified if it reveals sources and
methods you can take it out and I agree
to that in event when I sign up for the
sea
I've agreed to that 27 years ago got it
and I know you were talking about when
you roll today they can control me that
way or any CIA employee that way when
you're when you're speaking publicly
yeah I think most of us stay within the
lines now if I went out of the lines and
started talking to you about things that
are still considered to be classified
there probably is some sort of a
resolution that could take me to court I
don't know I know that they have taken
authors to court who have refused to
remove the material and had it published
anyway
and and they've they've confiscated any
money that was made from that book they
will they will do that I know is
repercussions if you do something if you
write it if you okay if you write it but
okay so I guess what I'm trying to find
out is rogue agents you know you see it
in movies you read about it in fiction
novels but I'm sure there's some also in
real life that you deal with how to see
I hold them accountable
Edward Howard was the first CIA officer
who defected to the Soviet Union and he
was he did it because he was so ticked
off because CIA fired him and we fired
him because he was stealing money coming
from the coffee fund he had done a lot
of drug use he had lied on his forms he
wasn't really he should never have been
hired we were getting him ready for
Moscow and then we fired him when we got
him ready for Moscow he learned the true
names of some of the most important
agents we ever ran and when he was fired
he went to Santa Fe New Mexico contacted
the Russians told them all the names all
the people that he had that he had
learned about the case that he was to
have run was a man named tolkachev
there's a book about him recently called
the billion dollar spy it's one of the
best spies ever that the CIA ever had
CIA ever had ever had in our history we
that man provided us with billions of
dollars in savings he gave us he gave us
the schematics the blueprints the all of
the information about their
next-generation radar on
airborne and on the ground he gave us
everything the Pentagon said oh my god
we don't have to do all this R&D we'll
start building the countermeasures now
and they did so we're able to build the
defenses for what they have not even yet
built this was just it was remarkable it
was solid gold and one of our guys
actually two of our guys betrayed him
and they arrested him and they executed
him because that's what they do
betrayed him and they executed the agent
that saved billions or they executed the
two oh yes great they executed the
Russian and our American CIA employee
who betrayed everyone went to Moscow
it's he executed or he was defected he
went to Moscow he's still active he's
still working he died he died we're not
sure he wasn't killed you're not sure he
wasn't killed I'm not sure do you know
how long he lasts them working or you
don't have any idea ah well I'm assuming
this is like in the 70s this happened
how long did he work for the CIA
nope so post CIA you want to Russia how
long was he he was there about 10 years
he was there for about I mean that's
plenty of time to oh he gave them he
gave him everything he everything he had
how much are you following with what's
taking place with Huawei with the the
China you know the China cellular
company with 5g5 do you think what do
you think about the fact that the boss
of UK's CIA their intelligence goes and
works for a while way and he gets
approval from David Cameron to be hired
by them I find it amazing you're okay
with that I don't know that uh I was
just in the CIA talking to our director
of DD SMT science and technology and she
was saying she's a woman CIA by the way
is run by a woman for five top people at
CIA they are women too
not that I'm a FEMINIST she was
expressing concern about that that's
what kind of what she wanted to talk
about we need to keep the edge there and
we are losing the edge and what are we
gonna do about it that's kind of like
call me going and working for Samsung
yeah you could put it that way wouldn't
that be kind of weird if that happens am
I the only one that thinks that's weird
for the former intelligence boss of UK
to work for Huawei in 2010 and accept a
job
think it's it's uh I don't know enough
about it yeah I guess it but it and
broad generalities
it seems very it seemed absolutely wrong
the only thing I think about I think
more like I bring that to us because to
us we're not UK we're not China so
that's their deal what they're doing
it's not our business but in you care in
u.s. if something like that were to
happen new companies typically go and
hire CIA agent former CIA agent that
you've seen yourself we're not really I
know that our some members of CIA I know
go out into into commercial when they
retired they go out into the commercial
landscape and they do this and they do
that the ones I know I don't know if
problems with them I don't know really
have that's control that's not something
that I that I have personally followed
got it they eat from your experience of
being in it for 27 years and now you
know with husband you know first husband
second husband what made an ideal CIA
agent if there were certain things to
say these were the qualities of somebody
that was very good at it I know you said
we were professional liars we will you
know pay to know how to lie but what
made it what made somebody a prolific
CIA agent if my husband was here this is
this is the question that he would he
would love to answer one of the
qualities that you need to have as a CIA
officer well there's that there's a
dichotomy because the people that we
search for we're talking operational now
we're talking sake case officers we want
big personalities we want gregarious
people we want people with really strong
interpersonal skills it's a big part of
their job that they be able to approach
people all over the world and convince
them that they want to be our friend and
they want to work for us we can't even
teach this stuff to them we have to find
those people or they have to find us and
they are usually larger than life
personalities that's why we hire them we
know them when we see them and then we
have to say to those guys it's almost
always guys by the way you could almost
save the world tomorrow and you can't
ever tell anybody what you did you can
recruit one of these soviet agents
that's going to give us billions of
dollars worth of intelligence but you
can never acknowledge the fact that you
were involved you can never
expect to get any pat on the back
any anything your ego has to be big
enough know just swallow this and you
have to have this this approval that
comes from within and you have to be
able to think that that is enough that's
a very hard thing and a lot of people
that start out wanting to work for us
they say no thank you
now I can't do that I can't do that home
I just thought about a bunch of
personalities let me bring in a Thai
personality that's good to talk to
people and it's driven and competitive
ghost gets the job done but there's no
celebration that's right baby you won't
believe what I did today I was dealing
with this Russian guy but I can't hop
that's the pinnacle that's the high
quality yeah
Tony thought that that was a sort of a
romantic quality that that your approval
comes from within he felt that way
it was he liked that himself because he
was an artist he was creative I'm
assuming he had a big personality he did
although the Parkinson's took away that
big personality so when when ben affleck
played Tony Mendez in the movie Argo
Tony and Ben Affleck went went on George
Stephanopoulos Show Good Morning America
Stephanopoulos said Ben a lot of people
think you really under plain that
character and Ben said have you met him
he's very quiet guy and Tony just said
over there very quietly because
Parkinson's just I watch that in him
sucks that stuff out of you my husband
was not a quiet man was thoughtful man
but he wasn't a quiet man well I wonder
how Ben played the role because he's
been playing how he is today or how he
was before then played the man he met
then played the man he met but he wasn't
like but the man he met had Parkinson's
but Ben didn't know that he had
Parkinson's we hadn't told anybody so
Ben just thought oh it's quiet like that
Ben interview with you to kind of get an
idea from your end on how he was know he
spent more time with Tony than he did
with me he spent some time with Tony and
Tony didn't say Ben by the way I have
Parkinsons you know this is not me so
Ben just played the guy he met and he
made a fabulous movie
oh it was an incredible movie I mean
listen I couldn't my dad watch the movie
and he got emotional ah watching the
movie because his sister my aunt was
stuck in the embassy when that took
place so while we were watching this he
he was he couldn't even watch the movie
says I sat in the theater after was over
what I can't even leave because my body
was a shock watching it reminded me of
what I had to my sister I can't imagine
how that must have felt it was very
realistic what they did that that
airport scenes in particular were just
even if you didn't know somebody there
they were still emotional I can't
imagine his reaction yeah no doubt yes
it's a very very well made movie and the
way the whole story you read about it so
the part about aargh one thing I read is
the fact that there's this 30-year old
is that true or is that just something
we are citizens here about like you
can't tell a story of what happened for
30 years and then we can talk about it
is there such thing as a 30-year rule no
designer was 78 and the movie came out
right after 2008 and that's 30 plus
years not that you know what I still I
still we've got other books we talked
about other operations we couldn't say
where they took place we still can't say
where they take place I don't think
there's a 30 year so how about this I
know one of the things I was watching
you talk about was how to tell a spy
like you're a spy how can you tell
somebody else is a spy you know you know
what I mean so you're you know with
somebody else how can you tell how do
you read that I mean on the street or
one to one or one to one is what I'm
talking oh I think you I think it takes
time and and meticulous attention to
detail and asking them about their past
and assessing them and and watching how
they respond to various things they're
almost signals that you give off on the
street it's easier than sitting in a bar
with the beer sitting in a bar with a
beer everybody just gets comfortable and
you have this conversation it's hard to
tell but if you're if you're worried
about surveillance if you're out on the
street you can see somebody who's
worried about surveillance so they they
have all kinds of body language that
they give off all little ticks little
plants is little tiny shoes and looking
in Windows and you know you kind of see
it so our officers in Moscow we trained
them not to do any of those things we
trained them not
look for surveillance but to always
assume they were there because they
always were there so don't go looking
over your shoulder don't go trying to
you know J walk across the street or
dive into a metro thinking you'll lose
them you won't lose them they'll just
know that you're a spy you'll you will
solidify their suspicion that you are a
spy and they'll come in tighter they
will and if you're in a car they'll do
this thing called bumper locking you
they'll get you they'll get so tight on
your car that you you can't do anything
you have to go home so I remember one of
the stories you talked about that there
was these two spies talking to one
another and they were counting and they
said 1 2 3 and that's not how they
Campbell was that story about that was a
movie that was that was a scene in a
movie what was it called some of the
Basterds glorious glorious bastards it
was a great movie I loved that movie I
was a scene in a bar there was a
Englishman a German man a German and
they were ordering more beers mm-hmm and
the Englishman who was pretending to be
a German held up the wrong fingers
he ordered he ordered three beers to the
bar he just put his fingers up and the
German just set up looked at him because
all of a sudden he knew but that man was
in the German a German wouldn't do that
a German would do that that was just a
small thing and I mean it ended up being
one of the goriest scenes I've ever seen
of shooting everyone in that bar
including the bartender because because
of the fingers but I made a point the
point was you have to be really careful
about all the small things very who is
that though how true is that is there
are those types of tales you pay
attention to sure yeah around the world
I mean if you're working in a foreign
country you want to know are there are
there what are the basics here what what
do I not do some places you don't touch
someone's bed everyone has these these
these areas you shouldn't go into but in
general it if you flip it on its head a
lot of Americans want to know how do
they know I'm American when I haven't
opened my mouth out how do they see me
when I'm just you know part of a crowd
and and it's fun to go down that list
and the tell-tale signs that we all give
off you know when I lived in the middle
I had to go to the airport maybe once a
week and greet a CIA officer coming in
on a plane coming in temporary duty TDY
I he what I never would know them I
wouldn't know what they look like
I'd only know that the 747 is gonna land
usually at 3 in the morning because
that's a good time to bring those planes
in and you're looking for your CIA guy
and I could stand there and watch this
crowd disembark disembark disembark and
I could walk up to a guy and say excuse
me is your name Jim I take him take him
to the driver we take him into town I
can find CIA people that way it was like
a profile that I could see he wasn't a
tourist he wasn't a foreigner how could
you tell though because there was a
there was like a dress code like almost
a haircut we it's like you can tell a
military guy from it from a group of
civilians you could see if there's a
marine in there you could tell marine
from the other military guys there are
all these subcategories I could find my
CIA guy by the way he dressed by the way
hit by his the bags he was carrying by
everything like it's him well they can
see us like that what was the best kind
of Intel by the way was it pictures was
that audio was a video what's the best
Intel you got the best Intel I ever got
that we ever got I'm having a
conversation with up with a major
bibliophile in the intelligence
community because it has to do with
cameras versus satellites and I said in
this book that my cameras I called him
my cameras but this it's my account we
had cameras that we could put in a pen
and we did put him in a pen and it was a
film camera but you could still write
with it for you to flip it over and you
could take pictures with it and your
boss came in and you can flip it over
and make a note take him to lunch or you
could put it in a woman's lipstick you
can have your lipstick at your desk
you'd be taking pictures your boss walks
in you can screw it up freshen your
lipstick drop it in your purse head off
those cameras we can put them in big
liars we could put them in key fobs we
can put them in any
no one knew they were there and you were
out of the camera you would get a piece
of film like this it had a hundred tiny
dots on it and every dot about the size
of a period at the end of a sentence was
a full eight and a half by 11 page of
text come on hopefully of the minutes of
the meeting or the agenda for the
meeting or because we were looking for
plans and intentions and you you want
those documents that's what we were
collecting now my bibley a graphic
friend says well the satellites they
they were holding their own and they
were fabulous right but the satellites
were collecting what was already there
they were telling you the status quo you
could count the missiles think of Cuba
you could you could see what was on the
ground and that was valuable information
the plans and intentions was more valued
this is my this is my case so I'm
thinking today what if you had someone
in North Korea who had the today's
equivalent of that and what if he's in
those meetings wouldn't you like to know
what he's thinking what what the leader
of North Korea what he's talking to his
top wouldn't you or Putin wouldn't you
love to have that camera in the room I
would that's the kind of information we
are we had an agent in Moscow who gave
us the the salt one in salt two
positions of a Soviet Union before they
went into the negotiations we knew the
cards they were holding we knew how low
how hot we knew what their lowest bids
would be their highest bids would be we
had the guy with the radar we had pink
offski one of the first agents that we
ever really really worked with in Moscow
he gave to John Kennedy during the Cuban
Missile Crisis he had all of the
information about the missiles in Cuba
he knew how many he knew their state of
readiness he know their range their
throw weight Kennedy had all this
information on his desk when he was
having that standoff with Nikita
Khrushchev
he had the information that that gave
him the ability to call his bluff put up
that blockade stop that thing in its
tracks that's what good intelligence
produces and it's not always visible at
the time later on these stories come out
when the equities when the intelligence
equities are no longer gonna be
threatened but good intelligence is
fabulous based on what you're saying
that's if you know my intentions like
you can find out someone's intentions
versus how many missiles you have I mean
you're pretty much getting that
country's next 5 move strategies on what
they're gonna be doing when we were
chasing that bin Laden tony was you know
in the media was always saying gee it's
too bad we don't have somebody in his
camp and I was I was always thinking and
how do you know we don't have somebody
in his camp I mean how do you know that
you don't know that tony said not just
someone he said you want his cook he
want to recruit whoever's cooking for
bin Laden
that's the person you want they're gonna
hear every conversation that goes on but
that was a that was a tough nut you had
to be a member of the family you had to
you know you couldn't get in the circle
without without belonging to his family
practically that was tough yeah that's
that it sounds like it would be tough so
how much based on what you saw that was
taking place versus what the media was
reporting how accurate was that my
friends in the military and he served 20
years and he went from Army to Special
Forces to highest level similar to Navy
SEAL Team six and he had a presidential
clearance and he worked under you know
Iraq Saddam was all this stuff and he
would say I said which media eat rice I
don't trust anybody he says half the
time we'd be watching stuff that's not
true yes I'm actually I'm in it and what
you're saying is not true how did you
feel when you're looking at the news
watching news saying no clear what
they're talking about way I never really
felt that they didn't know what they
were talking about but I sometimes felt
that I knew some things that they didn't
know that would come out someday and
probably change their minds you know
that's having and when I left the CIA my
friend said that's what you're gonna
miss you
miss that inside knowledge because it's
kind of a it's sort of a powerful thing
it's powerful but you can't use it it's
interesting to pick up the paper and say
give it two days and there'll be another
story there that's that's interesting I
think I think the attitude toward the
media has changed today
we weren't questioning the media like we
are now we we weren't relying on the
media at the same way that we are now
yeah questioned and reliance so you're
saying we didn't question neither they
will rely on it the media had nothing to
do with what we were doing we weren't
working for them we weren't providing
them information we were we were a
conduit to the policymakers in
Washington DC politics also didn't
really play a part when I was working I
didn't really know the politics of the
people I was working with it wasn't part
of the conversation it didn't come up
and I think people weren't as as
polarized into their positions then so
it wasn't an issue it was everybody went
out and voted but we never asked anybody
with able to vote with you what you do
wasn't a conversation thing so I've
heard of CEOs chief executive officer
chief marketing officer chief operating
officer what is it chief disguise
officer ah it was a great job Shiva
disguise that the CIA was I had a
worldwide staff
I had people positioned around the world
forward-deployed like the military does
so they could respond for it very
quickly had a big budget a robust budget
we use disguise everywhere in the world
but we used it in Moscow in different
ways because it was such a difficult
place to work it drove a lot of our
technology Moscow did how did defeat
Moscow my husband Tony had started some
R&D on on masks early on ten years
before me when he was in disguise I when
I came into disguise that was starting
to produce some fruit and one of the
first mass that came out of production
was was for me it was an
african-american man
it looked good it looked fabulous and
gloves so I showed it to my office
director we took it to the head of CIA
bill Webster he said oh my god let's
take it to the White House I said I
can't it looks good but I can't you know
I can't really walk it and talk it this
is not realistic it's just to show you
the capability he said one thing go make
one that you can wear so we did we made
a second one that turned me into a
younger prettier better coughs woman I
loved this mask I wanted to take it home
when I bet they wouldn't let me so uh
judge Webster likes it and he said well
let's take it to the White House I said
I don't have any I have nothing he said
don't worry just you know come with me
and so we did I went to his house I was
met at the door by the judge and his dog
the dog didn't like me barked at me
incessantly I went in the powder room I
put on the mask I got everything
right came out dog loved me they say
dogs don't like hats but evidently dogs
like masks so we went to the White House
we got stuck outside of the OL office
because they were going long and there
was like a 10-minute hmm period that was
I was a little paranoid I'd never worn
one of these masks before in public and
you get nervous nobody paid any
attention of course so I relaxed we went
in the went in the Oval Office there was
a circle of us Brent Scowcroft Bob gates
John Sununu
judge Webster me and another briefer and
I went first I was the first one so I
showed him some photographs of disguised
as we had done for him when he was chief
of disguise we said you you might
remember these he did I said so I'm here
to show you the next level he said so
show me I said well I'm I'm wearing it
and I'll take it off and show it to you
and he said no no no don't take it off
and he got up he came out walk and he
looked he went behind he's checking it
out he went back sat down he said
take it off so I just peeled off my face
John Sununu wasn't paying any attention
to me because he's making notes he was
gonna go next he had some things he
wanted to say to the president he
glanced up he almost fell off his chair
was it bad big man and he was startled
Bush really liked it looks but she was
smiling so we talked a few minutes it
was a it was a successful deployment I
was the first one to leave I went out to
play with the dog Millie and her puppies
and the White House photographer came
out she had been in the meeting going
around pitching ching taking pictures
she came out and said what did you do
what was that what was that I said I
can't tell you it was classified so it
was a successful briefing ten years
later I got a copy of a photograph her
photograph that they had airbrushed the
mask out this is the only photograph I
ever got so I'm sitting in front of the
president's guest with my hand in the
air and holding the mask
showing it to him and they airbrushed it
out so the picture in my library I don't
know what you would think I'm doing but
people say that they airbrush the mask
out yeah it was classified
I gave me the picture and I'm not seeing
the picture but I know you're seeing the
recent pictures because now we can talk
about masks a year ago I could not tell
you this story they were so good so what
did you say about because they have
allowed it now which to me you know what
does that mean sources and methods are
classified this evidently is no longer
classified perhaps they're not using
these anymore or maybe they've got oh so
good that what I'm saying has nothing to
do with the new ones I think that's more
like it
let me ask you how many times you guys
made masks for presidents to distract
the audience like they're duplicates out
there as well that we don't know about
oh we can't know the answer to that
question for the president
yes no never no no not that you know I
would never I would guess never what I
know
is never you know what I'm asking right
so there's you know I don't know Saddam
had all these yes that what you're
talking about that we have a picture of
Saddam you know in a boat on the
Bosphorus or something with his 26
Devils they're all paddling it's like 26
exactly alike it's bro yeah so we've
been we've never done that they're you
know about no I there's a long great
history of presidents doing that okay
but I don't know that we've ever done
that I got it okay very cool I mean
whence the Churchill did that lots of
people haven't done that
George MacArthur is supposed to have
done that am i I used to have caught
when I was chief of disguise I'd get
calls from the seventh floor they were
gonna have a party that was gonna be FS
a presentation there'd be something on
could we do some disguise scenario for
them
what's the seventh floor when he say
seventh floor that's the suits that's
the upper level got it we always said no
we said this is not an entertainment it
was I was a hard-ass when I was there
how much how much different is how much
tougher see Isaac CIA's job today would
social media or is it easier today
because all these cameras are you know
you have so much footage because your
camera guys are pretty much seven
billion camera people going around with
their phones recording is it much easier
to do their work today or when you were
it probably cuts both ways I would
imagine it's it's you know there's a
phone in every pocket on the one hand on
the other hand if you're trying to use a
cover identity if you're trying to use
the disguise and if you don't have a
telephone in your pocket that that
mirrors that face and that background
and I mean you know your shopping
history your everything your driver's
license you have to have your whole
lifetime in that phone in your pocket
when you approach an immigration or a
desk clerk at a hotel in a foreign land
you have to it all has to match that's
hard on the other hand we were the
technical arm of CIA we were the cue we
were the ones that did the bugs we did
the phone taps we did
that fake identities we did the
disguises with the audio all the
technical stuff that our case officers
needed we did we can take those same
tools that are making it so hard today
and use them in a positive way to make
it easier for us it's an offensive and
defensive shot oh so they can do it too
it's it's it's this kind of ridiculous
battle everyone though has an audio bug
in their pocket everybody has an
encrypted communication device and
everybody that's everybody has a
miniature camera in their pocket and are
you your substance you were in that
world are you paranoid about pcs
computers iPhones smartphones the camera
on the phone are you are you paranoid
about it because you were in the world
because you know more than we do if that
stuff is used I pay attention to what I
put online
I don't Bank online for instance you
know I'm not sure you can save yourself
anymore because no me your bank is
online if you're not they aren't and
they could still get hacked the thing
that the thing that makes me paranoid is
Alexa I got to tell you I have Alexis
all over my house she's stealing my
window blinds she's doing my lampshade
she's telling me the weather she's so
I'm like I wonder what else Alexis doing
and that's a silly form of paranoia but
but it's normal it's a lot of people I
have a 32 year old employee on my home
office his name is Mario he started off
getting everybody on Alexa and the other
day he's like I'm not using my Lex
anymore because he's you know she's
listening to what I'm doing I'm paranoid
so he threw away his Alexa and this is a
32 year old guy that's paranoid about
Alexis I don't think you're alone every
once in a while my Alexa kind of spurts
out come in it has nothing to do with
anything I didn't say anything
I'm walking by and she just says
something I'm like you know so it's it's
kind of a joke but yeah it's a sign of
what's coming how often were in a worse
yeah like for instance you work at a
company I work at Google I work at amis
I work at Morgan Stanley Merrill are
there employees who could potentially be
CIA employees CIA agents or no CIA
agents strictly works for the agency not
necessarily we have CIA agents
undercover
we have them working with private
industry overseas you always have to
remember that our our mission our
assignment is foreign intelligence fi
it's called we're collecting a flying
our people typically overseas if the
work is being done here in the States or
the targets in the States it's probably
the FBI is doing the work
so take the overseas piece of it we've
had people undercover in in various
large American organizations that the
cover job was that they would work for a
large American corporation in fact they
worked for the CIA
it's called non-official cover knock
knock officers they're out there they do
that job they go to work and report to
work and and actually do the work of the
organization that they're situated in
and then they do our work for us but
they don't accept payment from the
company that they're working for we pay
them much less what does that mean they
don't accept payments so when that
company pays them and goes into a direct
deposit CI agency takes that money out
and you get your salary CIA takes CIA
turns the big money back to the
corporation this is the understanding
with the corporation and they get the
much smaller CIA payment so to see this
so the corporation knows that that
employees working for the corporation
some person in the corporation's some
person knows someone is great usually
it's some very senior person in the
corporation so is the senior person also
an agent no they're just allowing their
governments to occupy a position for
cover purposes so they're okay with it
on a case by case basis this is not
widespread but it has been done got it
it's a NOC program got it that the joke
is that on occasion our officers have
found themselves in these non official
positions non-official cover positions
they've worked with these big
corporations they've seen that money and
they've seen us turn it around and send
it back and they say hold on a minute I
like this work I like this money and
we've lost them are they going to work
for the county by my and what guess yeah
you do know know if that's what the
person wants to do all the
good luck is it though as the culture
let him go gently is that sea is culture
if you if you lose a knock that way yeah
yeah they can do that got it
let's transition the movie I watched a
movie read Sparrow I think it's called
red Sparrow
Jason Matthews yeah Jason Matthews what
did you think about that I know Jason
Matthews okay I worked with Jason
Matthews he was one hell of a case
officer Tony and I trained him and
surveillance detection he showed us his
overseas situation which was awful I I
did not imagine that he could write like
that I mean the book did you read the
book Oh fabulous phenomenal movie the
movie was not so good I didn't think I
met Jennifer Lawrence that I was on a
stage with her New York's Times reporter
and we talked about the story and they
did what they often do with the movies
they watered down the story to make it
fit the arc that they that whatever star
I didn't like the movie I thought the
book was phenomenal his when he writes
about surveillance on the streets of
Moscow I am with him but it's just me
well that how much truth was there
behind what he wrote about I think there
was a lot of truth the one thing that
nobody really knows and I I haven't
really asked him is about the sparrow
school I don't know that there is a
spool but there are sparrows our our
people and a lot of innocent Americans
go over there and bump into them these
women who are schooled in seduction and
here they come they have gone after our
United States Marines at the Embassy
Clayton lonetree was the only the only
United States Marine ever convicted of
treason and what happened to him he was
an American Indian he met this beautiful
young woman who was working at the
American Embassy
her name was Violetta Shana he seduced
her they had an affair then it appeared
that he allowed some KGB people into our
embassy more than once then he got
transferred to Vienna and her uncle
showed up in Vienna and
you know I want you to give us the plans
to the Embassy in Vienna we want to come
in here to so he went to our chief of
station and confessed and he went to
prison he was there for eight years in
jail that's what a swallow the kind of
pandemonium they couldn't come out of
one of us can breath breath sparrows the
book names name of the book but it was
called spa life and based on what I yeah
so a swallow and sparrow are are almost
interchangeable God how much of that
practice is used in US intelligence you
know it's not we don't use that as a
tool that doesn't mean that there hasn't
been a seduction here or there but just
happens sometimes but it is not a tool
of espionage that we use I mean it's a
very effective method very fair because
men you know if you want to seduce men
you know they're typically they like
good food and they like it sex oh yes
they do and there are old stories and
and maybe there are some new stories but
as a concerted tool tradecraft it's it's
not that doesn't mean there haven't been
seductions got it there are some good
old stories maybe some newer stories
maybe a history of it with the East
Germans for instance with the Stasi it
was a tool of their of their tradecraft
especially when they went into West
Germany they had a group of men we
called them Romeo's they went they went
into Berlin they went into Bond and and
they they were assigned particular women
that were working in the West German
government they married them their
children it was the whole thing was a
mock situation and when the wall went
down the men went home and these women
are like really really I mean it was
their life and it was it was a fake and
that it kind of comes out of that Soviet
style of using sex as a as a bargaining
tool you know something that I hear a
lot John McAfee comes out and he's
founder of McAfee Antivirus and he comes
out saying I want to run for president
and it's pretty entertaining no one
takes him serious about him running for
office but he does make a good point
he says a lot of people are worried
about nuclear wars where instead of
being worried about nuclear world wars
what we have to really be worried about
is a cyber war because cyber war can
really mess up a lot of things
how much even your time or even today
based on what you know how much is the
CIA trying to work on preventing a
possible cyber war or that's not
something that the CIA deals with I
think they must be dealing with it they
have to be dealing with it it's out of
its out of my my field of vision at the
moment now I know what you know maybe
maybe you know more in that what I'm
seeing in the papers it's the new
battlefield if the Cold War was a matter
of settling the hostility without taking
the field of battle which it was then
the cyber war that's following it is
just going to be the new version I think
of the Cold War theoretically without
taking in the field of battle although I
understand there were some planes in the
air today I mean this is starting to
mean they'd have planes up we have
planes up and starting to look a little
dicey but but cooler heads seem to have
prevailed I think just keeping it in the
cyber borders it's gonna be enough so
they theoretically have bugs in our
system and now they're saying they'll
well of course we have bugs in their
system and this is just where it's at it
may it may supplant nuclear as the
ultimate threat it probably can do more
damage than nuclear if it's if it's
carefully done I mean if they shut down
the electrical grids if they shut down
banking system or transportation and it
looks like this could all be done I mean
everybody's over here worried about
climate change but hold on my agent
that's right but if they just turn
everything off the other day last week
our building was hit by lightning and we
had no internet or power for three days
we worked out of a hotel for for two
days what nothing yeah so that's just
the company I can only imagine if that
happens as a country what kind of an
impact that could have well you know
there's there's this it's a generational
thing we have a we have a family
graveyard in Nevada up north of Las
Vegas it's about 90 miles north it is in
the middle of nothing and nowhere it's
just there's nothing there there's no
internet there's none so when we go when
someone dies we'll take Tony there next
year we'll all go Vic probably 100 cars
will go up and all the young people in
the cars will drive with their hands out
of the window holding their cell phones
up trying to find some connectivity and
they cannot believe that there is a
place that there isn't an internet I
mean they really don't know what to do
if there isn't an internet it's scary
that is that's everything yeah it's how
we're connected today I mean that's
that's so if we lose our internet we'll
lose a generation
the next generation will have to learn
again how to speak how to talk out of
interact with people at it you know
mayonnaise are you saying it may not be
a bad idea I know what yourself no I
don't want to I felt something
okay so let's talk about the book so the
Moscow rules what tell us a little bit
about the book the Moscow rules is
talking about our our office that we
worked in OTS it was the the the the q2
CIA it was the Mission Impossible kind
of real-life it really was we we had
engineers we had electrical mechanical
we had chemists we have physicists and
then we had all kinds of very esoteric
specialties people that just did
batteries for their life not people that
did ink for their career ink
hot air balloons forensics we could make
anything we could make any kind of paper
we can make any kind of document could
actually make any kind of money but we
didn't because did you know that making
in other countries the money is an act
of war it's an act of war it's an act of
war and you cannot do it so we didn't do
it we could do anything and as we were
working we were involved in in these sub
miniature cameras in creating documents
that could pass through international
controls and coming up with encrypted
communications a lot of what we were
doing was trying to keep our foreign
agents safe trying to keep them from
being arrested because if they were
arrested in Russia they would execute
them and they arrested a lot of them and
they executed a number of them back in
the 80s and 85 was called the year of
the spy we lost we lost a whole stable
of agents some of them were lost because
of American traders so it was I was
compelling work it was it was really
very interesting the book is talking
about some of the links to which we
would go to invent the technology that
didn't exist yet it wasn't commercially
available most of what we were working
towards is now contained in a cell phone
encrypted communications the camera is
that all of it it's in your phone but
the piece in here that we've never
really talked about before was deception
and illusion in Moscow the hardest place
in the world for us to operate we had so
much surveillance that we couldn't work
you couldn't you couldn't walk down the
street you couldn't drive couldn't go to
your apartment they had bugs in the
walls even the American Embassy was
penetrated both with technology and with
people that worked there KGB was all
over it really
they were foreign nationals working for
us we had some ambassadors that thought
that was a good idea
so as chief in disguise
Tony initially went out to Hollywood and
he was working on disguised things but
he was very interested in the magic
community out there and he got involved
in it and he wasn't as interested in the
performances as he was in the
engineering behind the performances so
like how do you make an elephant
disappear on a stage they've done that
London for years and years and years
classical trick elephant walks on the
stage it's a big box people go in the
box they say yeah there's nothing in the
box the outfit goes in the box they
close the door magician talks for a
moment opens the door Elton's gone where
is the elephant
it's the classic idea of where's your
audience
what's going on here
what how are they playing with you so we
told them our problems in Moscow is it
okay you call it an operation we call it
a performance and magic the first thing
you have to do is figure out where your
stages what is your stage is your stage
a side walk down the street of Moscow or
is it the parking garage in the American
Embassy where's your where's your stage
then figure out who's your audience who
are you plane - is it the milli man that
who's guarding the the shack at the
Embassy that you have to drive by is he
your audience or is it the guys in the
car trailing you down the street or is
it the video camera in the parking
garage there were a lot of them so you
start dissecting your your situation and
then you start designing the illusion in
magic a lot of the illusions are based
on twins they don't actually have to
really be twins they can just sort of
look alike so when we started making
masks really good animated masks good
enough that you can brief somebody
wearing them
we could start replicating people we
could make a second you we'd have to
find some tall guy with kind of your
bill but you didn't have to look like
you and we could give him your head how
close do you get to it real close real
close we make it so that now there are
two of you then you can start playing
games with your surveillance wherever
they are you can do it in a car you can
do it on the street you can you can
switch people in and out and they think
they're with you but they're not you are
over here doing the work that you want
to do so there was the twin thing we
started working with something called a
jib a jack-in-the-box this was just
proprietary from Moscow nowhere else it
was a briefcase that the passenger would
put on the floor this would all be
choreographed - within seconds but you
would be driving down the street with
your surveillance behind you you take a
right-hand turn they'd be coming along
and then you take another right-hand
turn with that second turn you're in
what we call a gap and maybe it's five
seconds maybe it's
seconds and in that gap it's enough time
for the man in the passenger seat to get
out and for the driver to hit the button
on the briefcase and the dummy pops up
wearing the jacket the shirt your air
and your face and so surveillance comes
around the corner and there's still two
people in the car there's an old Russian
man walking down the street that's our
case officer and off you go those kinds
of deceptions and illusions we did a lot
of that but my favorite my favorite one
was called disguise on the run and what
we learned in magic is there's nothing
like a crowd to shield what you're doing
you can do anything in a crowd you can
walk down the street at lunchtime in New
York City and no one's looking so if
someone's walking toward you and they
see you walking down the street and
maybe you just grab your shirt and tie
and just pull it down because there's no
arms and it split at the back at you and
just roll it up and stick it in the bag
you can take off your coat and I do the
same thing or maybe you take it off and
peel it off put it back on backwards and
it's totally different you take a
backpack you put it in a shopping bag
you pull up a beanie out of your pocket
put it on some ear plugs in you have
your Walkman out now you're wearing a
tank top and you've got a sleeve of
tattoos going up it and my son did this
for up a wired.com video he's kind of
bopping down the street he starts out a
little businessman with a bag he turns
into this dude it's all tatted and all
and it's just you can do a lot of that
Tony sold that to our office director
with a 45 second demo he started as a
businessman with a briefcase and he
turned my by the time he got to our
office director who was 45 45 steps 45
seconds away he had turned into an old
lady in a pink coat with a shopping cart
full of groceries what else where an old
lady would have pink my husband yeah it
was what and and that was what convinced
our office director that we could use
this technique so we used that in Moscow
with one of the best operations we ever
ran one of the most important operations
we ever met took an American diplomat
and turned him into a Russian who even
smelled like vodka I mean he was this
old Russian pensioner who walked up to a
manhole lifted it and went into the
manhole because it was something in that
manhole it was so important it was the
beginning of a huge successful operation
collecting against a nuclear target in
Russia so the book goes in goes behind
the magic community and talks about how
we how we got into some of that
deception illusion stuff that sounds not
frivolous but it really made a huge
difference and what we like that what we
were doing that was Tony Mendez who was
an artist who's always an artist started
as an artist into this an artist he said
to one of the one of the writers that
was doing a piece on him he said you
know I've always been an artist I said
but for 25 years I was pretty good spy
for 25 years I was a pretty good spot
but the art I think in the end one out
tony tony was was something of a legend
that's yeah I bet I'm yeah of course
when you read about him it's it's
endless stories that come up yeah well I
appreciate you coming out and being
again some value tainment if you'd like
to order the book we're gonna put the
link below in the description side go
pick up the book and whatever you got
from the interview today I'd love to
hear from you message below if you
haven't subscribed to our channel do so
as well again thank you for being a
guess somebody Taylor thank you so much
appreciate you I loved it yes